you know what's up everybody is
International Master Daniel wrench here
for the chest comm YouTube channel and I
hope you are ready as you can see from
the title we are bringing this thing
back to the first chess openings video
that I did here for our chess openings
playlist that being more about the
Spanish free Lopez today in particular
however we're going to be talking about
the marshal attack which is one of the
most dangerous weapons at Black's
disposal for Ruby Lopez players and it
goes a little something like this
after E 4 E 5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop
b5 again if you want any more
information about the moves played up to
now you can check out the how to play
the Ruby Lopez or Spanish chess openings
video there over on our playlist to your
right after the move a six Bishop a4 is
the main line after Knight f6 castles
Bishop to e7 rook to e1 b5 Bishop b3
castles for black and c3 as I noted in
the how to play the route Lopez video
the first one and these days a lot of
players are choosing to play the move
order with h3 first as a means to
prevent the marshal attack which we're
going to come back to showing you
exactly why that does after we discuss a
little more about the marshal attack
after the move c3 white is preparing to
play d4 and the mainline Spanish as you
learned in that in our first video that
I keep referencing and I'm going to try
to stop doing that my apologies is that
after d6
white wants to get the move d4 that was
the whole purpose of c3 now first thing
you must do is prevent the pin of the
knight on f3 with the move like h3 but
after 95 Bishop c2 d f-- c5 d for Queen
to c7 we have a mainline Spanish where
there are different types of approaches
for black but the main idea is that the
tension regarding the pawns whether or
not white will push and close the center
and try for a King side attack whether
or not some sort of break in the action
will happen from blacks perspective or
whether the tension will simply maintain
itself around other plans is the main
feature of the game for the next 20 to
25 moves
however the marshal attack is the idea
of black in this exact moment right
after white has played c3 which if you
haven't noticed has slowed down his
development yes prepares d4 as I
highlighted but by
going down the development of the night
he is causing himself dysfunction on the
queenside right family dysfunction no
one likes that and black and strike with
the move d5 after each takes d5 Knight
takes d5 you would be right if you see
that hey doesn't that lose a pawn well
before you accuse Danny of being off his
rocker we take a little bit of a deeper
look and we see that after the moves c6
yes white has won upon however his Queen
side is entirely undeveloped and if
anyone knows the way you take advantage
of an undeveloped position in your
opponent's camp is to open lines create
open files and diagonals well by
sacrificing that pawn Black has just
done that created open lines in terms of
diagonals and potentially open files and
this moment white has two main ways to
approach the marshal attack the first
and most main line being the move d4
which Emilia opens the bishop and makes
an obvious attempt to complete
development and after Bishop d6 the rook
comes back black will immediately strike
against the Kings side with Queen h4 and
after the move g3 Queen h3 the game goes
down very interesting lines very
fighting lines with black threatening to
develop the bishop in a moan or two ways
followed by immediately challenging the
e-file and hopefully creating a mating
attack for more information on this now
you know what the marshal attack is you
have a basic intro here so you can
search for more games on the internet go
to chess comm and find more games if you
want to see how black wins those
positions noted should be that the move
h3 usually fails immediately to a
sacrifice where black simply has too
much facing this weekend King and
potentially threats along the open file
for white to deal with so g3 is a
necessary move believe it or not
the other main move the white has as I
said there are two is the choice of
playing d3 the major difference would be
that after the move Bishop to d6 rook
back to e1 Queen h4 g3 and Queen to h3
white intends to play this move rookie
for the idea is that it prevents Bishop
to g4 for black and if the move Bishop
f5 is chosen as an obvious form of
attack black and kisses Queen to buy as
it's now trapped on h3 however the
difference between this and the end the
line would d4 is that in this position
after d4 Bishop d6 rook back to e1 Queen
h4 g3 Queen H through rookie for black
will simply fall
with the Queen not allowing this move
again to trap it and in doing so he now
gains a tempo on the brook which white
will have to deal with before he can
think about developing so you see that
this idea of playing d3 is it means for
white to provide a little bit more of a
prophylactic approach to prepare this
move rookie four and meet the move Queen
to f5 with a developing move of some
kind now I'm giving a summary of two
main approaches for white d3 and d4 I'm
not necessarily saying which one is
better d4 would be suggested to be
better as it has been more popular
throughout history but d3 is also an
interesting idea and again if you want
more variations on how exactly black
succeeds with that attack you're going
to have to find more games yourself
quickly before we end this video we'll
come back to reminding you that the
reason the very simple reason why h3
prevents the marshal attack is that the
move Knight a5 going after the bishop
error is still not possible yet because
it loses this e5 pawn and so after d6 to
defend it white has time to play c3 and
transpose black didn't get to play the
marshal well what if black plays d5 now
after h3 instead of c3 white can simply
capture on d5 and now when he goes out
for this pawn the major difference is
that he hasn't taken away this square
for the knight so it moves such as
Knight to c3 immediately offering
exchanges in the center eliminating
minor pieces can only help white defend
the King side which starts to liquefy
black's attacking chances so in summary
you just got your world rocked once
again with the supernova of chess
openings here on the youtube chess comm
channel enjoy hope you enjoyed this
video and I'll see you around on chess
calm